peut-être n'est-ce pas envie de grandir
après tout
je veux que les choses restent telles
qu'elles sont
on n'arrête pas le temps Wendy que cela
te plaise ou non
[Musique]
tu étais en train de voler c'est à cause
de cette bestiole tu me prends pas que
le Pays Imaginaire c'est ce dont tu as
toujours rêvé
ni règlement ni école Niort fixe pour se
mettre au lit ni père ni mère et surtout
on grandit pas Wendy
ne prononcez jamais
son nom
[Musique]
je sais pas à mon frère
je vous ai manqué comme au bon vieux
temps parler pour vous vieux capitaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est peut-être la plus belle et la plus
grande des aventures
[Musique]